[Music]
I want to play a quick little newlywed
game with you guys this is just you
answering as yourselves you can write it
on the right board here how many kids
will you have three wives two question
mark that means two with room okay yeah
it's super early for that guy where are
you going to live so we've we've talked
about that a lot like Banksy or anywhere
you are so as that is NYC the next step
probably will you have a televised
wedding oh I don't even want to answer
that one why not it that's that's uh I
don't know that's like the next step of
craziness right yeah like gonna have
some time before that
who is your fiance's celebrity crush can
i spell this word
I need word hope it's a name did you
smell it irrelevant who wears the
metaphorical pants in the relationship
[Music]
[Laughter]
nailed it okay very last one it's a yes
or no is your fiancee emotionally
intelligent okay a wonderful global
intelligence little paradise you guys
thank you so much so glad that you both
have the emotional intelligence to find
each other to create a solid
relationship in paradise
[Music]
you